ولانه لا جهه تبنت الهجوم فما زال الغموض
يكتنف تفاصيلها روايته المصادر في
المعارضه السوريه اضافت شقا اخر للقصه
قائد فيلق القدس اسماعيل القائني كان
الهدف وهو الذي كان متواجدا في سوريا
لمتابعه مساعدات الزلزال التي ارسلتها
طهران لدمشق ثم حضر اجتماعا لحركه الجهاد
الفلسطينيه لكن غير موقعه بناء على نصيحه
روسيه الامر نفسه اكدته الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه شخصيه كبيره كانت مستهدفه لم
تسميها لكن هذه الروايه نفاها مصدر بفيلق
القدس في تصريحات لشبكه روسيا اليوم
وبمناسبه الحديث عن زياره قائان لسوريا
مسؤولون عسكريون اسرائيليون حذروا من
استغلال طهران للمساعدات الدوليه الخاصه
بالزلزال بهدف ارسال اسلحه ومعدات الى
ميليشياتها في المنطقه لكن يبدو ان تل
ابيب متيقظه لهذا الامر تحاول بين الحين
والاخر استهداف هذه الشحنات
عدم الاعلان طبعا اخرها ثم نهايه يناير
الماضي استهداف قافله شاحنات في المنطقه
الواقعه تحت سيطره ايران الشرقي سوريا على
ماذا احتوت القافله اسلحه مهربه بحسب
معلوماتي ايران انترناشونال خصوصا وان
القافلات تتبع الوحده 190 في فيلق القدس
ذراع الحرس الثوري لتهريب الاسلحه للمناطق
المتضرره من الازمه في المت
[موسيقى]
قاعات